[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera a tutti intanto vi presento la
mia gamba sinistra e la mia gamba destra
sobria la mia vita è diviso a metà
c'è un prima e c'è un dopo il confine è
un guard rail che si strappa le mie
gambette dal ginocchio in giù il 22
agosto del 2005
avevo 28 anni una chioma di capelli
corvini un'abbronzatura da paura
una carriera lanciatissima una grande
famiglia
un manipolo di amici super affezionati e
un fidanzato da almeno una decina d'anni
sapevo chi ero ed ero abituato a contare
soprattutto sulle mie forze questo mi
faceva sentire sicura imbattibile in un
secondo è sparito tutto io
giuseppina nata a versace sotto un cielo
fortunato che ha fatto di me la bimba
carina quanto basta di una buona
famiglia e mi ha regalato l'appartenenza
ad una terra dura e bellissima e alla
sua gente
improvvisamente non avevo più niente di
fronte a me un confine attraversarlo
oppure no provare a guardare oltre o
rimanere attaccata ad un passato che non
esisteva più
credo di aver fatto la scelta giusta o
sfoltito i bagagli e portandomi dietro
solo la luce chiarissima della fede e
quella forte e irradiata dalle persone
che hanno camminato al mio fianco ho
attraversato il dolore
al di là beh un grande dono
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ci ho messo un po per arrivare lì dal
giorno del mio incidente sono passati 14
anni quest'anno festeggiato e
quattordicesimo compleanno in mezzo ho
dovuto attraversare ostacoli abbattere
barriere architettoniche e mentale sono
caduta ho pianto ma mi sono sempre
rialzata mi sono guardata allo specchio
e ho ricominciato da capo
certo lo ammetto la famiglia e gli amici
sono state le mie stampelle
la curiosità mi ha spinta ad andare
oltre la fede lo sport mi hanno resa più
forte e consapevole
un viaggio a lourdes mi ha aiutato a
girare quella domanda perché a me che ho
fatto io di male ci sono tanti ladri
assassini in giro che scoppiano di
salute perché io devo perdere le gambe
poi davanti a quella grotta è come se
una voce mi avesse sussurrato di girare
quella domanda perché non a te che hai
tu più degli altri
in effetti è così perché non a me
viviamo in una società dove ci impongono
canoni di perfezione di successo di
bellezza ma sono davvero quelli gli
ingredienti che fanno la ricetta della
felicità
non lo so ognuno ha la sua ricetta io
trovate una mia quando nella vita capita
qualcosa che inevitabilmente ti scombina
a tutti i programmi per usare una
metafora sportiva come in una gara
se hai una testa fuori forte e un cuore
pulito trovi il coraggio di guardare
avanti con positività
rielabori la tua scala delle priorità
qualcuno la chiama resilienza quella
capacità di trasformare una tragedia in
un'opportunità coraggio fatica impegno e
amore e spudorato per la vita mi hanno
costretta ad affrontare sfide che io
stessa non credevo possibile vincere
sono passata dalla pista d'atletica agli
eventi in piazza per la mia onlus la
disabili no limits
un'associazione che ho fondato nel 2011
con l'obiettivo di raccogliere fondi per
regalare la stessa opportunità che ho
avuto io a quelle persone disabili che
non se lo possono permettere
sì perché oggi nonostante l'italia abbia
ratificato la convenzione onu dei
diritti delle persone con disabilità
quel diritto allo sport e ancora oggi
purtroppo negato e quindi per tanti che
non hanno le possibilità economiche fare
sport diventa un lusso quando invece per
me dovrebbe essere un diritto sono
passate dalla scrittura di due libri
alla tv ho vinto una gara dove le gambe
sono protagoniste proprio io che non c'e
leon o persino interpretato l'aquila
volando su piazza san marco durante il
carnevale di venezia
tutto questo e molto altro portandomi
dietro la cosa più preziosa che ho
scoperto di possedere e non parlo di
queste mie gambineri swarovski
parlo del sorriso lo stesso che ha
accompagnato da quell'amore spudorato
che ho per la vita e quella voglia di
contagiare positivamente la gente mi ha
permesso di approdare persino sui
palcoscenici teatrali che l'avrebbe mai
detto che io avrei preso a braccetto la
disabilità portandola alla gente con
normalità
si no ma lì da normalità perché la
disabilità sta negli occhi di chi guarda
dal 2005 ad oggi sono diventata un'altra
la mia vita nello specchio
nonostante la sofferenza la rabbia lo
sconforto la frustrazione non faccia
altro che ringraziare dio per l'amore
che mi dimostra ogni giorno ma del resto
chi ha mai detto che la vita deve essere
per forza facile ci ho messo anni ma
alla fine ho abbandonato la giusy di
prima per scoprirne una che mi somiglia
di più e che sa molte più cose ho
imparato che se faccio qualcosa di buono
e la condivido con gli altri mi sento
più felice ho imparato che i ragazzi
sono il futuro e solo loro mi possono
aiutare ad abbattere le barriere mentali
degli adulti hanno costruito attorno al
mondo dell'handicap
ho imparato che non possiamo decidere
gli eventi che capitano nella nostra
vita ma possiamo decidere come
affrontarli
ho imparato ad apprezzare tutto ciò che
o senza piangere per ciò che mi manca
ho imparato anche a modificare le mie
nuove bambine
adesso indosso una caviglia particolare
con un pulsante scusate ho messo i
tacchi non so se qualcuno che non vado
fiera dei miei tacchi
anche perché il piede si inclina
normalmente da 0 a 5 le donne mi possono
capire ma io ho trovato il modo di farlo
piegare 8 e quindi mette un tacco più
alto
ho imparato a correre per solidarietà
non solo per me ma soprattutto per chi
non lo può fare
ho imparato che ci vuole coraggio
ho imparato che i limiti si possono
superare
ho imparato che ieri è il passato domani
è il mistero
oggi è il dono oggi è il dono
se io non avessi rischiato di morire se
non avessi persone gambe forse
ci avrei messo un intera vita imparare
tutte queste cose
e chissà quante altre me ne sarei perse
vi dico la verità ma se io avessi una
bacchetta magica e un solo desiderio da
esprimere
una cosa è certa io non tornerei mai
indietro
[Applauso]
grazie